y
vale
saben que a los 13 años hubo un evento
que marcó mi vida y que marcó esta
primera vez que me toca estar en té de
c's resulta ser que en la secundaria
cuando avanza esto más o menos el pelado
que tiene ahí recién que cumplí 13 años
me pasó algo que realmente me dio el
tesoro que hoy les voy a compartir yo
estaba en el patio de la secundaria
federal donde estudiaba y un cuate
llamado alex llegaba y me daba lo que
nosotros en guadalajara le llamamos un
sopapo o un golpe en la cabeza luego se
iba y se reía con sus amigos no entendía
yo exactamente que se reía pero ahí me
daba un coraje por dentro pero a la vez
sabía que no le podía hacer nada porque
yo era el niño de 13 años que apenas sus
papás le habían dicho que ya no tomar el
ritalín porque habían sido diagnosticado
como hiperactivo y estaba este cuate que
después otro día llegaba y me daba una
patada en el trasero que hago y aunque
lo veía muy grande me pasó el síndrome
del chihuahua con el doberman no sé si a
ustedes les ha tocado los chihuahua
tienen una autoestima desproporcional
exagerada fuera de realidad empiezan a
ladrarle al doberman y el doberman así
como a mí pone uno de mi tamaño entonces
yo le dije este cuate que se llama alex
y que todavía lo recuerdo y le dije
sabes que nos vemos a la salida el
típico cliché nos vemos a la salida
la secundaria donde yo estaba a cuatro
cuadras estaba el parque de los juegos y
lo rete a unos buenos fregadazos en el
parque de los juegos evidentemente
sucedió algo conmigo en mi imaginación
yo veía como le partía toda su madre yo
me veía a mí dándole golpes en la cara
en la cabeza pateando los golpeando y
así nunca nadie más en la secundaria iba
a recibir el maldito bullying que nos
hacía no se llamaba bullying pero ahora
sé cómo o por lo menos yo no sabía si
así se llamaba llegamos al parque y él
llegó con dos de sus amigos y yo con dos
de mis amigos ese era el público
completo en mi mente justo antes de
empezar la pelea no se me puede olvidar
porque ese día marcó mi vida dije así te
va a ir empezaron los guamazos ya los
cinco o diez segundos yo ya estaba en el
piso y creo que es de las pocas veces
que he recibido patadas en las costillas
en el piso lo que pasa es que yo en
lugar de rendirme dije
me lo voy a entregar porque necio si soy
resistentes y soy dije venga me pare el
ya se iba riéndose con su amigos y le
dije otra vez lo curioso es que
empezamos en un jardín del parque y los
siguientes guamazos fueron en otro
jardín del parque y los golpes fueron en
el piso en la cara
increíblemente me volví a parar y le
dije venga ahora si vas a ver cómo te
voy a poner y así recorrimos todo el
parque en la batalla más épica que se
conoció en la secundaria federal en la
que yo estudié cuando me levanté sólo
escuchaba un grito porque ya no eran
cuatro en el público no sé si eran
siendo cientos o media secundaria era
muchísima gente pero no pude darme
cuenta de cuántos porque solo baje la
cabeza porque me daba vergüenza lo que
estaba pasando
y todo el mundo gritaba pera loca pera
loca haciendo alusión a que yo era una
pera qué
era golpeada por todos lados y que no
tenía capacidad de conexión ni de
reacción agaché la cabeza y me fui a la
casa caminando cuando llegue mi mamá me
dijo qué te pasó porque en mi cara había
evidentes signos de que algo había
sucedido y le dije jefa que así le digo
a la fecha me asaltaron
le había dado un amigo a guardar mi
reloj pero mi mamá no me creyó
con toda la vergüenza el dolor la
frustración y lo que traía me puse a
escribir poesía porque si algo había yo
aprendido
era al leer y escribir porque cuando
asesinaron a mi bisabuelo en la época de
la revolución mi abuela decía que lo
único que le dejó el hábito de la
lectura mi abuela tenía un librero en el
baño y yo a la fecha sin libros soy
extrañado
escribió una poesía con el rating de
mozart
no se me olvida y entonces llegó el gran
tesoro que les quiero compartir esa
poesía que me cuesta mucho recordar
porque justo cuando pensé que quería
compartir hoy un tesoro en ted estuve
tratando de recordarla de memoria y más
o menos decía voy sin rumbo fijo
ciegamente hacia la muerte entre la
sombra y la soledad de mi alma nací para
ser destruido y juzgado protestó ante el
tribunal de la vida y la sociedad esa
poesía fue un tesoro porque en ese
momento no lo entendí pero en la prepa
gané un concurso de poesía y no se
trataba de ser competitivo sino se
trataba de ver que había convertido el
dolor de la batalla en una poesía y un
día un maestro creo que era el de
sociología no me pude acordar bien dijo
el que ganó el concurso de poesía debe
ir al psiquiátrico y empezó a leer la
poesía y yo estaba ahí algo había
aprendido o era más rebelde un poco
porque me levanté y le dije maestro ah
porque dijo está enfermo el que escribió
la poesía y yo le dije sabe que yo no
estoy enfermo la enfermedad está en él
papel yo me curé escribiendo
y el el grupo le encantó el cotorreo yo
creo que desde ahí vi que tenía otras
cualidades distintas cuando me invitaron
a té de c's yo dije que les computó de
mi vida profesional animal o no sé quizá
esto sea mi vida profesional pero es más
bien un tesoro que amo y dije como le
pongo este a esto que hago
recicloterapia el arte de reciclar la
basura y convertirla en algo que sea
fértil que sirva el arte de convertir la
emocional en algo que nos ayude
porque a fin de cuentas la es el
abono y en ese sentido les quiero decir
que los siguientes 29 años
mi regalo más grande el tesoro más
grande ha sido vivir de escribir algún
amigo un día me dijo yo quiero escribir
para crecer mi marca personal yo le digo
a mi me gusta escribir para quitarme las
marcas o por lo menos para convertirlas
en otra cosa porque para mí es algo
sagrado es un proceso hermoso que me
sigue acompañando y que de alguna manera
me ayuda a canalizar las cosas y en ese
sentido la recicloterapia ese arte
yo quisiera compartirles como creo que
se puede hacer aunque no espero que lo
tomen simplemente soy como un amigo que
les comparte esto les puede servir quien
sería yo para decirles que hagan
vida pero saben una cosa creo que lo
primero es romper un paradigma el
paradigma de que el fracaso el dolor la
frustración y hasta que te pongan una
madrid en la secundaria es algo malo han
visto que a todas esas emociones hasta
les ponemos el nombre y ñoño eso de
emociones negativas
son potencial puro son alimentos para
escritor para escultor para bailarín
siempre y cuando encontremos un camino
para transformarlas en ese sentido
escribir es un camino pero la danza es
otro camino como ustedes pueden ver si a
mí me imaginaba peleando y a la hora de
pelear era diferente pues lanzando me
iba peor
pero yo ahora veo en mi hija que les
pongo ahí que a fin de cuentas ella
convierte la danza en una manera de
canalizar toda su inquietud y toda esa
energía porque a la mejor hasta salimos
de familia medio cargados de energía y
hay que ver dónde la ponemos yo no ando
buscando dónde me cargos y dónde me
descargo y escribir ha sido uno de los
elementos más hermosos que me encontrado
cuál es tu vehículo cuál es la forma en
la que tú conviertes la emocional
en energía pura y estoy seguro que más
de alguna vez lo has encontrado por
supuesto no basta con eso porque
entonces lo que pasaría es que si a mí
me volaron y convierto esa energía en el
es convierto esta sensación en energía
pura lo que va a pasar entonces es que
me voy a dedicar a volar a otros o sea
no basta con convertir eso en energía no
sería recicloterapia completa si es que
este término es válido porque no lo van
a hallar en internet yo lo busqué porque
a fin de cuentas fue lo que se me
ocurrió cuando me invitaron acá espero
que alguno de ustedes lo pongan y ya
quedaría recicloterapia pero entonces
que le falta esto le falta que
encuentres un propósito donde canalizas
eso porque si no no funciona
y en ese sentido mi ídolo es batman que
además acaba de cumplir años porque
porque a batman a bueno a bruce wayne le
matan a sus padres yo siempre me quiero
imaginar esa es la historia que me
cuento que fue a los 13 años porque a
fin de cuentas hay muchas muertes de
muchos tipos y la muerte es una fuente
de inspiración espectacular dolorosa
le dolió pero bruce wayne convirtió su
dolor en una misión ser un vigilante
oscuro que cuida de una ciudad y si me
fuera a la psicoterapia por lo menos en
la manera en la que yo le estudié me
dirían batman bruce wayne es un
neurótico y no lo resolvió bien
pero cuando andas más en la creatividad
la neurosis está lento si alguno de
ustedes le han dicho que está neurótico
tiene mucho talento les recomiendo más
la creatividad que la psicoterapia la
pregunta es cómo lo conviertes en lo que
necesitas les quiero compartir que con
los años
encontré otros vehículos porque quizá es
mucha energía en la que circula
normalmente con mi vida y son muchos
defectos los que tengo entonces
recicloterapia no sólo es la basura
emocional sino también es convertir tu
obscuridad como dijo fernanda en tu
mejor elemento y en ese sentido fíjense
que encontré otras como tengo tanta
energía pues me hice corredor y descubrí
una cosa maravillosa con el tiempo
descubrí que yo no tengo talento para
las peleas callejeras en un vale todo me
moriría de hambre pero aquella vez que
me gritaron pera loca pera loca pera
loca yo lo vi que estaban diciendo
tienes una resistencia brutal
así he podido correr 10 maratones y voy
por el 11 en seis semanas
no está el no sé si sea talento o podría
decir que los maratonistas somos
sobrevivientes o que hacemos de la
resistencia a nuestro virtuosismo y en
ese sentido creo que podríamos ver que
la persona que es obsesiva con la
limpieza podría ser la mejor enfermera
que encontráramos ustedes no quieren una
enfermera hippie
mira carnal todos somos uno carnal esta
jeringa lawes todo con tres way te toca
a ti llegarle no queremos una enfermera
dañada neurótica enferma y está en su
lugar porque a fin de cuentas está
canalizando lo que hace les comenté que
además me daban ritalin pero me a
pendeja va muchísimo con el ritalín
entonces mis papás sin mucho
conocimiento dijeron qué hacemos con
esto porque el doctor dijo que yo jamás
podría terminar de leer un libro
escrito 11 y no les puedo negar que mi
deseo de venganza con un doctor que no
conocí alguna vez ha sido buena
inspiración
entonces esa imaginación porque yo no sé
si te era hiperactivo o no ya no me
vuelto a hacer el
que me hicieron de la cabeza pero lo que
sé es que mi mente siempre está
imaginando cosas y entonces lo que hice
es convertirlo eso en algo y ustedes
pueden ver que ahí está un corredor este
corredor es su servidor pero en esa
historia se llama luke skywalker
y lo que es carbonero está siendo
perseguido por lord vader el señor de
los calambres
y entonces realmente cuando yo salgo un
maratón veo que el olor vader me habla y
si ustedes conocen bien la historia de
starwars pueden ver que el orbe jdr a
fin de cuentas aparentemente es el
villano pero es anakin es el elegido al
final es el que te redime y esa voz que
me está friegue y friegue y friegue y
friegue en realidad a fin de cuentas es
la que me hace entrenar
tiene un sentido probablemente el
emperador sea la ansiedad pero no vader
y lo convertí en un personaje y luego
acá en el maratón de roma que trato de
buscar a los personajes de la ciudad
pues resulta que era saturno devorando
personas pero devorando corredores pero
acuérdense que saturno cronos para los
griegos saturno para los romanos es el
dios del tiempo y saben que ese es uno
de los grandes enemigos de los
maratonistas porque se va comiendo las
horas y los minutos cuando tú quieres
hacer tu marca personal cuando corre y
roma- y lo pude plasmar en una historia
a fin de cuentas en lo que me quedé fue
que saturno nos come el tiempo a todos y
que nunca le iba a ganar a saturno y que
mi pelea era conseguir pequeñas
eternidades como este momento en el que
estoy con ustedes que el tiempo se
podría parar y que el saturno
está recibiendo un golpe en el hígado
diciendo están deteniendo el tiempo y
están disfrutando este momento pero les
digo algo al final del camino nos va a
ganar y como nos va a ganar nos conviene
más disfrutar de la batalla y así se fue
construyendo esa historia con puros
defectos
yo a fin de cuentas
y ahí empecé a jugar con un corredor que
tiene aventuras con personajes de las
ciudades en las que están saben otra
cosa que me encantaba ahí era que además
tengo cierto trauma con el sexo entonces
decía es otro defecto las ciudades los
domingos cuando corremos maratones están
desnudas por ejemplo la ciudad de mexico
es una hermosa ciudad pero normalmente
se viste con un tráfico
maloliente de la fregada solo se quita
la ropa y cuando ves reforma desnuda te
puedes fundir en las curvas de esa
hermosa ciudad y empecé a jugar con las
ciudades hay algún momento me convertí
en cuauhtémoc y cortez me iba
persiguiendo el desgraciado y cuando el
kilómetro 30 me estaba muriendo decía
mátame porque cuauhtémoc le decía mátame
y cortés me dijo no ahora acabas el
maratón porque quiero que todos
los mexicas vean que pueden ser
dominados lo que él no esperaba es que
yo iba a llegar hasta insurgentes
y aunque a cuando tenemos el chingo me
convertí en vicente guerrero
y estar corriendo y convertirte en
alguien y apoyarte de tu fantasía es una
belleza al final es curioso
recicloterapia es que todo eso que me
pasó se pudiera convertir en una imagen
en un texto y por eso quería yo
sintetizar les mi participación en tres
cosas muy sencillas uno rompe el
paradigma de que de que basura es
malo lo único no dejes la basura dentro
de ti porque se pudre tampoco la vi
antes al güey porque los demás no tienen
la culpa encuentra tu vehículo para
transformar esa basura en potencial puro
lo segundo encuentra un propósito y si
le encuentras un propósito seguramente
la enfermedad que te dio no es algo
negativo es una oportunidad de que guíes
a muchos cuando vivan en esa misma
enfermedad todo lo que nos sucede
probablemente lo podemos convertir en
eso si cambiamos el paradigma y si
pensamos que la basura es el combustible
del futuro
se imaginan ustedes cómo sería este
mundo si a todos nos enseñaran a
convertir el enojo la tristeza y el odio
en combustible creativo
a seguro que estaríamos en otro mundo
buenas noches
[Aplausos]
[Música]